hi um
hi Sergio
hi Bill
hello Miss how are you hello
good to see you so did costia join
um let me just check if he
maybe could not uh
let me just make sure he's not in the
oh yeah he's asking for the password
does he need a password
uh
Vision need one I think he should be
neutrino which email he's using to each
other have since this uh
[Music]
he should not need a password
foreign
okay
Sergio do you see a email from him or is
he well I he was just speaking me two
minutes ago asking for the password and
I replied that he probably doesn't need
a passport
um he's probably taking I asked him to
check his email he's probably taking his
email I also sent him the link that I
use but I don't know if the in my link
is no no I think so so let's let's uh
I'll check in the meantime
[Music]
maybe he doesn't have a zoom account we
didn't use zoom that much
it could be that
oh there he is okay he's joined
looks like
uh Costa are you
[Music]
um
so apparently he had to create uh Zoom
account but he joining he's having
trouble with the microphone okay okay
good we're getting closer I think I'm
sorry
yeah I think we're getting closer maybe
you can start if you want up to you but
no it's okay let's take a minute yeah
that's good
we just don't use you know
soon that much normally yeah
hello oh hi question
uh I did not have an account and
apparently there is a lot to go through
before it starts working okay well glad
you made it
great so so shall we get started
um
okay so well welcome everyone uh so
today is the last uh colloquium for the
for the uh for this for the spring until
until the fall
and um we have a very fitting colloquium
today it's a great pleasure to have uh
um Sergio and costia here from Google
um and uh to tell us about uh not just
the latest their latest experiment uh I
think it's a 70 Cubit Quantum you know
random circuit sampling Quantum
Supremacy experiment but also uh to tell
us about uh a lot of the
uh you know the theory work that has
gone on behind it so
um you've all um you know uh Sergio has
spoken in this kadokim before he he had
the the content group at Google and he
he did a lot of the
um the theory work behind the original
experiment and this experiment and
question uh is in the group he he does
condensed matter Theory and he's been
involved in both this experiment and the
time crystals experiment and so on so so
really looking forward to your talk
today and uh and the panel afterwards so
uh sent you
great thank you very much
almost for the
introduction
oops um
uh Sergio I can't I think you're muted
okay uh now you can hear me right yes
okay let me see what happens when I
serve my slides maybe yeah
I think you're muted again
okay that's a bit weird as soon as I saw
my screen
it mutes me
uh maybe we can unmute you after you
after you share
should we try that
they work can you hear me yeah it works
yeah okay great I don't know why when I
saw the screen it needs me perfect so
you can hopefully see those lights as
well
now if you can't see the slide I can't
see this oh really
he says your says I'm sorry in the
screen
huh
um
sorry my slides not so in anywhere
you didn't see much lights anywhere no
um oh yeah so I'm doing a screenshot if
I go to discuss world before could you
please try seeing them again okay I'll
try again
uh you know what I'm gonna try
obviously in the top let me just do
this again maybe this will work more
return three in a whole window
is it working now yes can see okay great
okay perfect sorry
great so okay A bit eventful uh yeah so
thank you I was saying thank you very
much almost for the uh imitation
tutorial here and yes indeed I'm gonna
talk about
face transitions in random circuit
sampling I random so we got something in
general so this is
um
with course there
uh let me see if I can move the slides
perfect and yeah you can see the place
great so let me give you a little bit of
outline of the main things we're going
to talk about so
um as we said we just we did recently a
new random circuit sampling experiment
and one of the reasons why we do random
circuit sampling is because it's a
benchmark of the system Fidelity so the
Fidelity of uh the whole circuits the
whole system
uh in experimental Quantum processors
and it's very important for us to
measure Fidelity up we keep improving
the system logic's relative Gates but
the Fidelity of the whole system so it's
a benchmark of fidelity and assignment
work of fidelity repeated this same
experiment that we did in 2023 but these
times with 70 cubits instead of 53 and
60 more gates uh so we did 700 to 2
Cubit Gates compared to 430 I think it
was in different 2017 but because we
have improved the Fidelity of the
different components uh now we obtain
you know for a circuit with more cubits
are more gate the same fidelities into
the Fidelity as in 2019 so that's good
for us as of using random circuit
sampling as a network of system fidelity
but random circuit sampling is also a
computational benchmark meaning a
benchmark
where you can compare the computational
cost of this particular computational
task so sampling the output of a noisy
random circuit against all known
algorithms in a super computer let's say
I think this remains actually the only
interesting computational Benchmark
where you can compete against a
supercomputer for experimental Quantum
processors so uh that's what we did in
2019 but then classical algorithms have
improved a lot in the meantime they were
actually able to reproduce the sampling
that we did in 2019 already
uh so now with more qubits and more
gates we have also been studying all the
classic algorithms are the Improvement
across algorithms we improve them a
little bit ourselves and we come with
the following slightly optimistic
estimate if you were to try to do the
sampling that we just did now on
Frontier which is now the largest
supercomputer with all the improvements
of algorithms that we know about uh it
comes out to 50 years
um so I guess quantum computers remain
ahead
and finally as Uma said we're also going
to talk about well costi is going to
talk about some of the theory that we've
been doing in the meantime and this is
um
this is the aim to answer the following
question is there some noise limit after
which we can actually claim that we're
using
the full size of Liberty space so that
you know entanglement remains useful in
random circuit sampling up to some given
noise limit
um so the answer to that is jazz and
there is a phase transition actually
within the weakness regime where we can
explore the full humidity space and the
Star News regime where it does not true
anymore the the wave function kind of
works apart into a correlated components
so that's a phase transition of course
they will explain we actually kind of
serve this phase transition
experimentally so it's a noise industry
in this phase transition that we
observed experimentally
um of course you know the experiment
itself with 70 cubits in the weakness
phase that's important and and it's also
important about things well not only
because in astronomist redeemed you
cannot you know try to do fluorescent
Implement marking uh uh and random
circuit something you know several
things break down but among others uh
this is also related to spoofing sir
having multiple very interesting
spoofing algorithms um proposed lately
and we've protested against this profile
algorithms you need to be at least in a
weakness regime
so that's going to be the the main ideas
that we're going to talk about uh before
we get to random circuit sampling itself
let me
um
give you sort of a bigger context so
what is the roadmap for Google in
Quantum computing so um in in 2019 we
did the first person of random circuit
something in this premium we're gonna
talk about today that an improved
version
um we just announced a few months ago
um so most of our roadmap is about
building a polterge aircraft that
quantum computer so most of our roadmap
is about error correction Quantum mirror
correction using the surface code so we
just announced a couple of months ago
what we call the logical give it
prototype and that means that for the
first time we were able to increase the
distance of the surface code for
distance 3 to distance five and observe
that The Logical error actually goes
down instead of going up because we're
adding more qubits that have more noise
but they have linear component errors
that The Logical air went down for
distance three to distance five so it's
a prototype
um and we will see there is still too
high to us to scale it but the point is
well we want to decrease the errors and
then eventually increase the number of
qubits so that we have
um at the next Milestone what we call
Mustang 3 what we call a long leaf
logical qubit so this will be a local
qubit with a coherence time that can be
measured in seconds or minutes instead
of microseconds with error correction
and we expect to be able to do that
around well 2025 plus so maybe next year
that is 26. and anyway there are more
milestones in a roadmap until eventually
um
perhaps by the end of the decade we
actually have an aircraft at quantum
computers are probably a pro uh I've got
quantum computer
um not just an experimental processor
meaning you can program it and it won't
have errors and it will run for a long
time and for that we need around a
million physical keywords and a much
lower physical error component errors
that we have now
so um the way we measure the progression
in this roadmap or the main thing we're
working on now let's say
is reducing the component errors
reducing the physical errors that's
actually more important right now that
scaling the number of qubits and the
reason is that well in the plot in the
right you see index axis they got
distance in the surface code and the
y-axis The Logical error per cycle
and the gray line here this is the
experiment that we just announced and
what we want to see is that as you
increase the conditions error goes down
and we measure that with a parameter
that we call Lambda which is the ratio
between distance three divided by
by sorry distance five distance three
divided by distance five so you want the
error to go down you want it to be more
than one
and it went down but only by like four
percent which is not enough to scale so
we want to for instance
uh in the near term get to Lambda 2
which means reducing the device
performance the component Errors By
around a factor of two and if we manage
to do that then we get a land of two
where the error The Logical error goes
down as we increase the distance from
three to five and eventually for Master
Three we will need a random Lambda Force
the arrows the local area goes down by a
factor of four as we increase the
distance in other steps so that around
distance
um 15 or 17 which is um roughly you know
between 500 and 1000 physical qubits we
actually have a long leaf uh and only
um logical qubits so these will be like
the mouse and three reading this is
where we want to go so we're focusing on
lowering um
physical errors improving device
performance so that means increase in
Lambda and and then the scaling kind of
at the same time
great
so now let me uh turn back to the main
topic of the talk today which is
um random Quantum circuit sampling okay
so what we do in random Quantum circuit
sampling is we have some experimental
Quantum processor in a 2d architecture
so this is
um what the architectural likes with
just 18 qubits we're going to be running
the experiment that we're going to
present today with uh 70 cubits but this
is still 2D
and then we
um run a Quantum circuit that we choose
a random so we choose the single cubic
Gates random and then after the single
qubit Gates we do layers of two Cubit
Gates they to give it gates are I swap
like
so they are kind of an eye swap with
some extra
phase an extra control C phase the
reason why we use this isob likes to
Cable Gates is because we want to
maximize the spread of entanglement so I
swaps um or you know it's also related
to computational costs
or try to protect against the spiffy and
things like that or reaching a regime at
which cross entropy works so this is
kind of an optimized gate
um in a nutshell Express entanglement
faster than let's say a control Sienna
to give it a random gate so that's what
we use that and also we optimize the
single qubit Gates a little bit so we
use a discrete gate of single qubit
Gates they are halamar like so they are
pi over two rotations on the XY plane
and
um well this is the discrete gate set if
we choose um
the access according to these values of
P so this will be the access
X Y minus x minus y they're Clifford
Gates and an isop is also Clifford but
then we add these other Gates which are
axis in between and actually plane
uh to have no clip or Gates which is
very important for the computational
cost claim so anyway this is the the
random gates are just choosing random
single qubit gates from this set
and again these set of gates is
optimized to spread entanglement as fast
as possible
um
there is also a
technical point which is when we to use
the discrete the discrete error side we
need to do what is called phase matching
um so what that means is uh when we
Implement physically this ice swap light
gates to qubit Gates
uh we get an extra phase an extra C
rotation and the qubits so if we do not
compensate for that extra gate rotation
so we don't control it we don't
compensate it we just declare that to be
part of the circuit then we get extra
faces so then uh the gates that is
actually continuous with some there are
still Pi half rotations on the XY plane
but with an axis which is random not
just discrete so there is less control
in this case uh if we remove these extra
faces that we get when we implement it
to give it Gates then we do the face
match discrete gate set so this is kind
of a technicality but it's harder to do
the experiment on the non-face on the
face match case which we did actually
this year
okay so that's the idea uh in a nutshell
we Implement a random circuit with
single qubit Gates uh which is a random
from this gate set and to give it gates
to the eye drops to spread entanglement
but then in an experiment we actually
have noise so we need some another model
of what the noise
um what the sampling looks like when you
have noise so here is a very simple
model that works well often so the this
very simple model me says that because
you have noise you're gonna actually
sample from a mixture of the ideal
probabilities so these are the real
probabilities according to the ideal
random Circuit of a beta string s but
because you have noise you sample from a
mixture of the ideal probabilities with
the uniform distribution were all beta
strings have the same probabilities and
Noise makes the system the probabilities
of the outcome more uniform
and the intuition behind that is well if
you don't have noise then you have
um coherent interference of
Quantum you know five man Parts if you
want in a random circuit so these
coherent interference gives you Speckles
like you know laser it gives you
probabilities which have output stream
probabilities which are higher than
others so in these Speckles of a laser
you have red points and dark points but
if you ask noise if you don't have a
fully cocaine Evolution then you tend to
get these more like diffusive light
which is not coherent and then is more
uniform light so that's an intuition
um you can actually argue this more
physically why this model often works
well or more formally like in this paper
and in this mixture between the ideal
probabilities and the uniform
distribution there is this very
important parameter which is the
Fidelity and which you can understand us
the probability of having no error so
with when you have no errors you're
assembling for an ideal probabilities so
with your ATM you sample from the data
probability when you have one or more
errors we feel little women have you
sample from the uniform distribution now
this is only a simplified model this is
another technicality
um but in the experiment uh this model
doesn't really apply
uh so we can you know we have another
model which is a bit more complex but
only
um everything we do also works under
this model and the main point is that
whatever the noise does
well the ideal probabilities are still
quite guarantee concentrated they're
bright spots of beta3 to high
probability but it's pretty
flat is distribution is called
anti-concentration so the noise does not
concentrate the output that's one
property that you want of the noise
which makes sense noise does doesn't
tend to concentrate in a few beta
streams and more importantly the noise
whatever the noise does to the
probabilities of your business strings
is something it's uncorrelated with the
ideal probability of the video stream
this is sort of the kit property and if
you have these properties then for most
of what we do like that I will explain
on the simplify model
um you actually
can make it work on this more realistic
model so it's a technicality but uh just
to keep it in mind
okay so now that we have a model for
what we're actually doing experimentally
so with some player sample beta streams
from these um noisy distribution what do
we actually do with these strings when
we most of what we do is called cross
entropy benchmarking and what that means
is we sample let's say a million bitter
strings
and then we Define a function of the
ideal probabilities so for the beta
streams that we obtain in an
experimental sample
we calculate what is the ideal
probabilities of those with the strings
and then we Define some function of
those ideal probabilities which is kind
of another one
so here is an example we calculated the
operabilities we multiply by the two to
the number of qubits so this number then
is
order one instead of one or two to then
and
um we average uh these numbers over the
sample bitter strings and we normalize
with a minus one another example is
again we calculated the probabilities we
normalize them but now we take the log
and we do like a different normalization
so these functions here of the ideal
probabilities of the video streams that
we sample is what we call
cross-enter payments marking
um we do other statistical tests as well
I call more of a Smirnoff that you can
look up in the papers
so why do we actually Define these
particular functions with
um this particular offsets well the
reason is that for large and updates
when the output becomes
anti-concentrated or it approaches the
but with respect of a random Quantum
state which is this Porter Thomas
distribution where the distribution of
the fittesters is potential so for
definitely arithmic or more
um it turns out that this particular
functions with these particular offsets
the linear cause entropy of the lowering
mythocentropy are an estimator of the
Fidelity and the Fidelity remember is
this parameter that we introduce as a
parameter in the mixture of the noisy
sampling which corresponds roughly to
the probability of not having an error
in the circuit so that's why this random
secret sampling Oracle Center payment
marking is an estimator of the system
Fidelity and Nissan experiment that we
want to do as we increase the number of
qubits and and reduce the errors to keep
measuring what is the Fidelity of the
whole system
so let me give you a quick intuition for
why this particular functions
um like the linear cause entropy is an
estimator of fidelity so this is what we
do let's look at this term with a devset
um we just do an average over the
samples we do an average of the
normalized ideal probabilities
and the samples are come in the simplify
model again you can use the other
slightly more General model but let's
just keep this model in mind in the
simplify model the samples come from
some noisy distribution which is a
mixture of the ideal probabilities with
the uniform distribution
so then if you average
um these numbers when you're sampling
with these probabilities and you get two
terms
okay let's look at this time first this
stems just come from here from the noise
which we're modeling as a globally the
polarizing Channel or a uniform
distribution so let's get the sum of the
probabilities
from here the two to the N consists this
two to then so these are some of the
ideal priorities which is one right
and then these other term well these
other term is actually you have some
ideal probability here because you're
sampling with some female ETF from the
ideal distribution
but then you're operating these numbers
which have another ideal probability so
you get probabilities a square
so this term is the second moment of the
distribution and here's the distribution
which is an exponential distribution the
second moment is different from the
first moment
so then this term is different from that
term and then
um you just need to offset by one to
really extract the parameter of so
that's an intuition you can do similar
math with the logarithmicrocentropy but
the pointy or other functions but the
point is that um the ideal sampling
gives you a different
um
a different result because your average
teenager probabilities gives you a
second moment so it gives you a
different result at the first model so
that's how person to be benchmarking
works and then they're fairly General
conditions then it gives you an
estimator of the Fidelity which is very
important for us
great so now
um let me
um present the the results of this
experiment that we just did again
uh so we use 70 cubits the x-axis here
is the depth of the circuit so the
layers of the cubic Gates and the y-axis
is the Fidelity the priority of an error
that we estimate as just explained with
fluorescent rivench marking so 70
keywords
um is kind of too many keywords to
calculate the ideal probabilities uh
comfortably or actually we don't know
how to do it at least know that these
steps so we cannot do cross and
privilege marking for the full system
but we can break the system in two
patches calculate the Fidelity of its
parts
right because it's now only 35 gigabits
we can calculate the probabilities and
then multiply them so that's what we do
at different depths and those are the
green dots for instance
or we can do three patches and well when
we work from two to three we remove some
gates so it's a slightly higher Fidelity
so blue is with three patches and what
is very important is that
um we can say well the Fidelity as I was
saying is passed it to be the
probability of having no error so you
can multiply the Fidelity of all the
gates into systems the probability of
not having an error in any component
and that will more or less correspond to
the Fidelity that we Master with cross
into business parking if everything goes
well if we don't introduce crosstalk or
things like that and this very simple
model which is what we call the discrete
aeromologists multiply difficulties of
the gates does the continuous line and
it more or less agrees in the two
patches and three patches with what we
measure with cross entropy and then
finally we take data with 70 qubits with
like 70 millimeter strings that we put
online uh at this 24 we cannot really
calculate the Fidelity but we just put a
bit of sensor there so we did the same
in 2019 people have actually been able
to check the fidelities
so here's the result
um and again in a nutshell as I said at
the beginning we're doing the same
experiment as 2019 but now with 70
cubits instead of
53 and 700 Gates or multitude Gates and
we obtain a similar fidelities in 2019
and this is the non-face match case
meaning we're not controlling the these
faces I was talking about from the two
qubit gates if we control the faces
which we can do now because
um we upgrade our software and things
like that uh we got a slightly worse
Fidelity we lost like a factor of two
infidelity because we have to do some
things to remove these extra faces that
we just wanted to create but it's not
too bad this is still
um I think it's 0.07
um it's okay we'll use a factor before
it was
0.17 percent if we do if we don't do
face mating with face matching so it's
fully controllable for fully control
gate set
is um 0.7 percent
okay so how were we able to scale this
experiment
um well we reduce the error rate you
know the components without introducing
cross locker and things like that so we
can compare the single qubit error rates
in 2019 to 2022 so what we just did and
we've got uh well it improved by 30 so
now it's like around 10 to the minus
four
the two qubit error rates and these are
by the way poly errors when would you do
errors in all the qubits at the same
time the two qubit gate set improved by
35 and the readout improved I like their
faster of uh two-thirds on uh 66 percent
so by improving everything the
components and scaling the experiment a
little bit we were able to do this spray
man with much bigger volume if you want
so now is when we compare with them
um all known algorithms so the algorithm
that works best and there has been a lot
of nice Improvement on this algorithm
for random circuit sampling but it's a
more General algorithm is tensor Network
contraction so let me explain you a
little bit how tensor Network
contraction Works to simulate Quantum
circuits again it's a it's kind of a
generic algorithm so here is my quantums
haircut where this is my initial estate
this is some output bit stream for which
I want to calculate the ideal
probability
according to this haircut and these
boxes here are the two qubit gates so
this is just my circuit and now I want
to think of all my Gates as tensors with
two input indexes and so I put indexes
so what you do
a tensorable contraction well you have
all these tensors you group them
in some way that you kind of have to
optimize so this is hard to do in
generally and that's one of the things
that have been profound in this paper
how you choose the order in which you
can track your tensors but once you
choose the order you basically contrast
these tensors and you get
sometimes we're with Summer indexes it's
just a bigger tensor and you just keep
redoing this group in tensorship and
Contracting them until you contract all
the tensors and then you get an
amplitude
so this is just a an overview of cloud
algorithm Works um again
um demolition the details and these
details have improved a lot in the last
few years
um so we take all these details and
improve them a bit more and we can
calculate basically
um what is the number of flops uh with
the latest transferable contracts and
improvements are a bit more to calculate
a single amplitude so to do the process
that I just explained to you just in
flops assuming that you have infinite
memory
so now constraints in memory yes the
flops and we see that in flaps the new
experiment is six orders of money that's
more expensive than in 2019.
these numbers are now quite stable
because I think we think we have a
fairly good handle on how to choose
optimal contraction orders if you ignore
memory constraints
yeah you have a plot of how the
computational costing plus has been
improving from a furnace experiment here
to experiments from usdc like here's the
new experiment
so you see a nice Improvement of
computational costs over the years
you can also introduce memory
constraints and efficiencies numbers and
and try to get an estimate of what will
be the
time it will take to sample a million
meter strings noisy samples
um in something like Frontier which is
the largest supercomputer you have to do
reaction sampling which is a small
overhead from going between amplitudes
and samples
because there's something actually but
it's not a big overhead but there are a
lot of extra tricks when you do a
million samples so these numbers are a
little bit more fluffy they might still
improve but anyway taking only known
improvements and improve them improving
more results
um like we're giving estimates return in
order of magnitude better than the best
estimates we think that the latest
experiment we're presenting will take
around 50 years in a frontier
so this is a plot of the computational
hardness measuring flops where the
x-axis is the number of qubits and the
y-axis is the depth and if you take some
fixed number of qubits let's say here
should be 70 which is this experiment
initially has increased the depth the
computational cost
changes a lot so the different lines are
flops right so you see a big change in
cost such potential actually increasing
cost as you increase depth until it kind
of saturates around this point so that
means your state is maximally entangle
and then adding more depth does not
increase the cost exponentially because
it's just linear it basically you just
have the full wave function now and 99
is just a linear increasing cost so you
want to make sure that you are at least
this depth Within These boundaries well
it's at least a score Defender so that's
why our circuits are pretty deep to make
sure that we're here
and yeah and the rest gives you an idea
of uh you know how the cost will change
if you change the number of qubits for
death
sort of keeping the same Fidelity okay
so another
um
very important algorithm is based on
matrix product state simulations so let
me give you an idea of how that works
um so here is the your initial State and
then you're applying Yates so you get an
output the state right so this is just a
state vector
um so what you do
then inspired by matrix brother States
is you want to break this state Vector
into two halves
and to break them into two halves you
get some indexes in the middle you
normally do this if you can with a
singular value decomposition and this
indexes are related to the singular
values the reason why you want to do
that is because if there is not a lot of
entanglement then you can
remove a lot of the singular values
because they're very small if there is
an entanglement and you got um a state
now which is well you just store the
fullest Industries are there two to then
memory but here if you only keep Kai
um indexes here in what is called the
dimension sorry this will be an N over
two this these are two n over 2 indexes
here because it's half of them sorry
about that two n over two times Chi
which is the bond Dimension so if I if
you imagine the N over 2 there this
state can be a lot easier to store than
this state and the trick here is you
have to
um if you want ideally do a supervisory
composition and drop
um there are singular values but then if
you drop too many of them then you start
paying a price so the finality drops and
the Fidelity drops uh sort of ideally
the square of the singular values that
the Fidelity is the square of the
singular value is that you keep up to
whatever is your body mentioned if you
order them and just keep the larger ones
which is what you want to do
foreign
well it's important to study this type
of simulations so this is new newspaper
inspired by actually these are the
references
uh people I mean work out these
algorithms for random circuit sampling
so what we have done is well first of
all we derive an inequality which
probably was known already
um so just based on Jensen's inequality
you can bound the Fidelity
of your reduced status after you drop um
singular values you can drop them you
can bound if you then it is the square
root of just this is analytical the
square root of chi which is the one
dimension times the
Square
this is the purity of the reduced
density Matrix the reduced and
sedimentary of this call for these other
the purity of the reduces event is kind
of a matter of entanglement so this is
analytical bound
okay so what is interesting is if you
remember these were single Cubit gates
in the discrete gate set which were
either Cliffords or non-cliffords and it
turns out that if we drop them on clean
for then the average reduced Purity is
the same as if we keep the non-cliffer
gates but if we do eye swaps with these
Clipper Gates then we can calculate it
efficiently what is the redisperity
because then it's all clear for so we
can calculate efficiently there with the
spirit of paper circuits so the average
is the same with clippers and
non-cliffer so long history sort with
numerics we can calculate this number
efficiently for a given depth in average
and so that's what we're going to do um
we also derive another bond for the
ability but this one is numerical we
basically get rid of the square root
another factor of 4 there
anyway so um these are the plots for
what is the computational cost is
um to make sure that we're protected
against this kind of algorithms and we
have very high entanglement
so
um let's just look at the numerical Bond
if you want so as before on the tensor
networks the x-axis is the number of
qubits and the y-axis is the depth of
number of cycles of two Cubit Gates
and as before the this is just memory by
the way we're not saying how do you do
this in our very composition or anything
like that this is sort of the minimum
memory that you need
uh which we borrowed with this numerical
abound on the Monday mention and at 70
cubits we say well once you're here in
this experiment that we just did
um the numerical one tell us that you
need more memory that you could feed on
Frontier even if you use external
storage and you see the same feature as
with tensor networks that initially the
memory required changes a lot but once
you saturate entanglement.saturate you
know you didn't win anything but going
to more depth because you're already
busy just to doing one truncation of MPS
um you know adding more more depth
doesn't really help
great so this is um all I wanted to say
and now costly is going to talk about
this
um space transition cost you want to try
this on your screen or solai
try to keep going from my end
I will try to share uh
yeah you need to stop sharing this code
so I can do it
okay
okay so uh
do you see my slides
yeah it's good
uh yeah so I will talk about noise and
use phase transition
and uh the relationship to what Sergio
was talking about will hopefully become
clear uh as I go um and the idea is this
we are looking at random circuits
and uh in random circuits what we do is
uh we start with a product State and
apply a random single keep it Gates and
fixed to keep it Gates
and we apply them in our local
architecture
uh so in one date would be a bricklayer
but uh order of gates as shown here
and we take this circuit sufficiently
long the idea being that we want to
prepare an approximately uniformly
random Vector from the Hilbert space
and this uh is a typical state for my
Hilbert space is nearly maximally
entangled and this is kind of one of the
ways of thinking of why it is hard to
simulate the output of a random circuit
noise drives the system towards a
maximally mixed state which is a product
state so kind of counteracts the uh what
random circuit is trying to do so in
reality we have a competition on these
two processes and the natural question
arises at what noise level uh we are
using the Hebrew space of all of the
qubits right
or in other ways
asking the same question is can a
smaller number of qubits have the same
computational power
right and this is what I'll try to
answer uh one way to answer this
question is using linear xzb because
this is an estimator of fidelity
I'll quickly remind you uh that when
what we do when we calculate linear xzb
we take a bit strings absorbed an
experiment calculate probabilities for a
given circuit for them and calculate
this quantity
here averaged over absorbed sticks this
can be thought of as averaging over
actual experimental distribution over
bit strings
and using this formula yes as Sergio
already explained we can analyze a very
simple instructive example which is an
example of global depriving Channel
model of the noise right that uh
introduced in detail uh it's basically
saying that our density Matrix is a
Fidelity times the random State we
wanted to prepare
Plus
uh
sorry because still I think we lost you
so we can see your video costly about uh
sorry the the screen but so how your
image is frozen and we cannot hear you
anymore
uh
hello yeah we can hear you
okay so now I can I guess continue if
it's better it seems like internet
interestingly it's slow
uh can I continue yes please
um we don't see our slides now
[Music]
interesting
yeah that never happened before I guess
uh do you see my slides now
and yeah
I did share the screen
uh
you do not see the slide still
it says you have started screen sharing
but uh
I don't see the
lights yet
yeah I am trying I am sharing the whole
screen
[Music]
okay fine
try again
uh is this do you see my slides
no not yet
huh
I am doing
yeah for some reason it doesn't share
system audio okay
interesting
it seems like I have the same issue as
the searcher
Okay so
yeah okay it's I can see it now
do you see the now the full screen yes
okay so I can continue
um yeah the idea is that from Google
deeper Rising Channel we can expect xzb
to equal to Fidelity however of course
the noise in our devices is local it's
quite far from there and in this talk we
will be interested in the boundary
between the regime where exhibit
converges to Fidelity and one exhibit
doesn't conduct suicidality and
uh how does it connect it to the point
with which I started I will say that
this is actually this boundary is
closely related to that question or how
many qubits are actually useful at a
given level of noise and it will be
instructing
to consider uh the simplified model
which we call the weak link model
and the first in one dimensions and this
uh model is consists of two we split the
system a one-dimensional system of
qubits or this crosses are qubits and
rectangles are couplers between them we
split them into two parts a and b equal
to each other and to each of the parts
we apply the bricklayer random circuit
with noise
and we treat this uh coupler between the
two subsystems can be as special and
apply it with some different period T
different from other Gates and we wanted
this T and then we will characterize the
Noise by the Fidelity of a layer of
gates which scales with the number of
qubits N and the error per qubit per
unit time
so we can understand two uh kind of uh
limiting cases using perturbation
theorem this was uh actually converges
of the probation theory was analyzed
previously theoretically
um so we can say that for for example
for a limit of T equals to this period T
equals 2 which means that this uh Red
Gate is actually not special at all it's
applied in the same bricklayer fashion
as our other gate for we can have noise
we know that the
polarizing Channel there is Convergence
to the polarizing Channel model so the
density Matrix can be written in this
form where row AP is a ideal and
schematics of the whole system can be
and uh it's uh is multiplied by a
Fidelity where we apply D layers of
gates so F to the D and we as I showed
before and and there's also that the xzb
in this case is fidelity
more interesting is the opposite limit
if a period is infinite
and in this case we uh expected A and B
are independent from each other so the
density Matrix is a product at the same
time because we apply a random circuit
uh we can uh again that's efficiently
low noise expect that each subsystem
converges to the polarizing channel so
the dense schematics of the whole system
is a product of the two depolarizing
channel Expressions now if we substitute
this into the xzb we get this expression
which is not just a Fidelity of the
whole system
but also this additional term which uh
has a slower exponent and this
additional term originates from
uh contributions here in the density
Matrix that have a a form of maximally
mixed state and half the system and then
uh ideal random Vector that we wanted to
prepare in the other half of the system
and there are two contributions like
that and also you can notice immediately
that in the maximally mixed state is
immune to noise so the Fidelity of such
contributions will be square root of the
Fidelity of the
call system because this is half the
system and the second term actually
dominates
so we see that xzb it actually converges
to something very different from
Fidelity and the reason for that is
because our state of the system is
actually a product status very far from
what we expect you know from a random
state in a Hubert space
now we can now consider a more
interesting case of this period being
large but not infinite in this case we
can solve the model
and this expression for infinite
a period is modified in a very simple
way where in the second term we have a
additional Factor Lambda
which is applied every time we apply the
uh this entangling gate bridging
subsistence A and B and this Lambda is
coefficient between 0 and 1 and it means
physically basically one minus Lambda is
the probability for A and B to be
entangled after we apply this bridging
gate
and
um
so Lambda is kind of a probability to
stay in the product State now we have a
xdb that is a sum of two terms both of
them scale exponentially with the uh so
there's a competition of two exponents
so we can see that depending on the on
the ratio between the basis of this
exponents the exhibit or converges to
Fidelity or converges to something else
we can call this a weakness regime where
it needs to be converts to Fidelity and
strong noise version
and we already see that this is an
exponential switch between the two
exponentials and this is a a short
switch right so indicative of a phase
transition to make it even clearer we
can introduce another parameter which is
a fidelity
divided by xzb the Fidelity of the whole
system divided by xzb and I just repeat
the expression for the exhibit here and
we expect for this ratio to converge to
one in the weak noise resume where
a first term is dominant and converge to
zero because uh Fidelity is much smaller
than xzb in the strong noise region
and uh
we can
uh
study the behavior of this order
parameter as a function of the noise
strength so this on the vertical axis I
show this order parameter and the
horizontal axis is the noise strings
again this is error per unit time so it
scales with n number of qubits and at
very low noise so it's zero here we
expect this uh water parameter to be one
at a very large noise to be zero and in
between is a crossover
and this crossover
it becomes sharper and sharper as we
take longer and longer depth right as we
would expect from the analytical
expression and this lines here colored
lines are numerical simulations of the
actual microscopic model where D the
color corresponds to a different depth
from cyan we tend to all the way to
Black 55 so we see that the
this crossover becomes sharper and
sharper as we take the larger and at
infinite depth it becomes a through
discontinuity so this is a
signatures of finite size critical
scaling a signature of this discontinued
a phase transition and this is also a
good way to identify actually a
convenient way to identify a transition
point in experiment as well
later
now we can now construct a phase diagram
remembering that this uh we Define the
Fidelity per layer as this quantity in
terms of uh error per qubit per unit
time
uh so the critical uh noise strength
corresponds to those uh basis of two
exponents equal to each other and for
the gate we are using I swap Gates the
centanglin bridge gate is I swap we can
calculate Lambda explicitly it's one
quarter and we obtain explicit
expression for the critical
uh noise strength as a function of this
T the period with which you apply uh the
gate and we can compare this uh well now
we can construct the phase diagram where
on the horizontal axis again this is the
controls parameter which is the error
per unit time the vertical is this
frequency or one hour period of
application of entangling gate and the
solid line is this expression analytical
expression separating the strong noise
and weak noise regimes and the blue dots
here are the numerical simulation of
macroscopic models we see that at a very
low frequency where we expect this
analytics to work well indeed the
numerics analytics analytics can cite
and as we as the this link frequency
approach is 0.5 where 0.5 corresponds to
period two so this is the where this
bridge is actually not special at all
just a regular one-dimensional chain
so here we see some deviation which
means that from from this on a simple
analytics this means that that an
internal dynamics of the of the uh each
half of the each subsystem becomes
important but more importantly we still
kind of see the qualitative features so
the existence of this transition uh
extends from this weekly model all the
way to 1D chain
and the question of course our
experiments that Sergio was describing
are in two dimensions and we can
ask the same question numerically so we
can construct a phase diagram where
again the horizontal axis is the error
per unit time and the vertical is the
number of links we are applying and with
such that in the here and the lowest
values we're going to look at is we're
applying only one link between left and
right
but applying it with the periodicity of
our circuits and then uh
all the way to applying all of the links
across the device and we see that the
dependence of the how many links to
apply is actually quite weak we also
study different sizes so this different
shapes correspond to different symbols
correspond to the different sizes we see
the change is not the big and we study
different gate patterns
this is a way to different choices of
how we apply groups of to keep it gates
in parallel
and this is also doesn't lead leads only
to a small change in uh location on the
phase transition So based on uh all of
these studies and different parameter
different details we can draw a
a lower bound on the critical noise
actually
on this plot assume vertical again
because the dependence on the link was
weak so it's kind of it seems like it's
a bulk effect
and we can therefore extrapolate this
diagram to a larger systems right now we
can do a experiment uh I don't know if I
should keep going or uh I should wrap up
at this point
um why don't you finish up how long
would it take you
um maybe of five minutes yeah that's
that's fine please uh please uh yeah
so these were yeah I showed me medical
simulations we want to verify that this
actually goes on in our experiment and
for that we need to add noise in the
experiment to control to tune
of course we we already made the lowest
noise possible for this experiments so
we can only go into a larger noise and
this is done by including this random uh
small angle rotations where angles are
choose chosen in such a way that they
match the single qubit error we want
and then we can
now control and experiment this uh
horizontal axis so the strength of the
error per uh per unit time and we can
use this order parameter and the
crossing point
in this final size scaling
to identify the transition points for
different T different periods of the
applying the link between subsystems and
we see that it it lies pretty close to
what we expect
theoretically and numerically and we can
repeat the same in 2D and see that the
results are consistent also in two
dimensions and the interesting question
is of course we are on this phase
diagram it's the 70 qubit uh
was discussing and just calculating the
parameters we can put the star which is
the location of this
uh
in this phase diagram we are our system
is so we can conclude that this well
within the weakness regime
right given that we Define this boundary
and uh
so in this sense the the what we are
measuring the xzb actually measures the
Fidelity of all 70 puberts and in that
sense you need all of all of the 70
cubits are being used
right you cannot get this with 69 cubits
for example
uh so formally this transition can be
justified
and this is done by analyzing the
circuit average linear exhibit for which
there is an exact mapping after circuit
average
the quantity the linear exhibit that's
defined here again it Maps exactly onto
a partition function of a classical
model so for M qubit system depth deep
the classical spin model will be n times
d
and the partition function so so the
correspondence is kind of to give you a
flavor is shown here we have two bits
single to keep it Gates and measurement
and on the right side we will have
instead of qubits we'll have sites which
can be in one of the two classical
States
for a simplified version or for a actual
model that describes the experiment
three states actually
and uh each uh
entangling gate corresponds here to a
four spin interaction which we can
obtain explicitly and the measurement
corresponds to local field and more most
importantly in this model we can
explicitly include noise which is an
analog of a local field as well
and therefore analyzing this partition
function if we find we find the
discontinuity in the first derivative so
this is the first or the first
transition
uh and uh yeah so we can Define uh
carefully the thermodynamic limits for
this transition in this in this setting
uh now why is this phase transition
noise and use phase transition
remarkable
the answer is here in this blue box
noise induced phase transistor is an out
of equilibrium Quantum phase transition
that is sharp at Finance noise per unit
time
uh now this out of equilibrium Quantum
phase transitions have attracted a lot
of attention in the physics Community
condensed matter in particular it's a
it's a transition that happens in the
wave function it usually doesn't have a
standard thermodynamic
signatures or signatures in Spectrum the
examples are many body localization or
measurement induced phase transitions
and uh for most of these transitions
what happens is that noise is
detrimental like they are broadened by
noise and become crossovers however in
our case the noise is a control
parameter and the transition remains
Sharp yeah
yeah that finite noise the reason uh
there was a proposal or analysis rather
of a rather different transition but
similar in spirit
uh in this paper but delete a runoff and
to see that it's a kind of different
mechanism than noise at which that
transition happens is uh much larger
than the noise we are talking about
like the the noise-induced phase
transition I discussed in this talk and
that we are identifying in this case
this really happens near the maximum
entanglements in the whole system
uh
and that's kind of the
the normal team right for it well to
conclude
we uh
uh use the linear xzb cross entropy to
identify first order phase transition in
the that is uh basically a change in an
Abrupt change in the Dynamics of the
system that distinguishes this weak and
strong noise resumes
um
uh we can we put a lower bound on this
in two dimensions and we show that uh or
70 qubit experiments in a weakness
regime
uh
uh and we can observe this experiment
experimentally in this transition and uh
at the end we can also say that there is
implications for spoofing algorithms
there is an analogous basically of
similar Origins phase transition of the
first order separating the circus that
can be spoofed and then cannot be
removed
and uh I'll leave this for the panel
discussion thank you very much
great thanks
so much
um are there any questions before we
move on
uh hi hi hi can I ask you hi emo yes
please thanks thanks but thanks for the
night very nice talk I just want you to
understand a little bit more about this
noise-induced transition in the picture
of classical stymac model you mentioned
that this is a noise-induced first order
transition so as as I would imagine
that's a competition between two
symmetry breaking Fields I guess one of
the Symmetry breaking field is your
noise and I'm wondering what is the
other symmetry breaking field
or or am I right about this
understanding uh as the face first order
transition
yes I mean if this it is a competition
between uh two exponents right and the
one exponent is uh uh just a Fidelity
and the other exponent is a combination
of the uh kind of the the rate at which
your circuit converges to its Quantum
cows
uh and and uh
effective noise right and some Fidelity
so in this two two simple weekly model I
have the second term which contained
Lambda M the half system fidelity
right so this is the competition these
two processes
oh so you mean the uh the the tuning
parameter T is serving as another
symmetry breaking field
frequency of applying a weak link
between two side
yes it also controls the the location of
the transition yes
okay okay I'll have to think about that
okay uh if if I have time can I ask
another quick question so when you do
your final size scaling you are it seems
that you are only tuning the devs rather
but not tuning the system size have you
also tried tuning the system site and
see how the crossing goes yeah yeah this
this diagram yes
yes it also becomes uh sharper right uh
well okay so if we if we fix uh Epsilon
n the question is how do we uh skill
yeah if I still allow M to vary then
this will be becoming sharper and
sharper also exponentially and they they
cross at the same point
uh yes for this weakling model they are
okay thanks
yeah but this is not actually necessary
in general that this can be uh broadened
a little bit
uh
the the yeah
okay thank you thank you
okay there's there's another question
let me give you a mission to ask the
question here could you go ahead and ask
the question
um
do you wish to
okay pass on the
in the webinar would you like to you
have your hand raise would you like to
ask a question
I think you're muted
okay
um
all right so maybe uh
there are no further questions uh
uh
uh okay
um maybe if you can stop sharing your
slides and we can move on to the panel
um because there
okay
it's uh
so
um
great uh
let's um
okay so as as the videos are being
penned up for the panelists let me let
me start introducing the panelists uh
um we have uh sunroan Choi from MIT uh
uh soon one of this PhD at Harvard he
was a military fellow here at Berkeley
now at MIT uh he's he works on strongly
interacting Quantum anybody systems and
he's he's thought extensively about
um random circuit sampling and face
transitions in them so very appropriate
for this
um
um it's uh Bill caffeman many of you
have already seen here bill um uh got
his PhD at Caltech was uh was a postdoc
here at Berkeley and is now on the
faculty at University of Chicago uh bill
um works on complexity Theory but but
he's I think one of one of the people
who knows
um the most about complexity of random
circuit sampling and and
so again
um great to have you here bill and then
um our last analyst is uh Alex delzo who
um got his PhD from Caltech and then and
is now at AWS so Alex did uh did this uh
very nice work with uh Fernando brandow
on how local depolarizing noise leads to
this the kind of global depolarizing
channel uh that Sergio and costia spoke
about so
um
um so shall we start the panel by just
getting getting your reactions uh you
know comments on the talk and and we can
start that off as a as a discussion
should I start yeah sure please yeah
maybe I can start um
um thank you so much for Sergio and
Constantia for through the amazing talk
and also I'm very happy that you know I
can watch this talk in real time and see
how they are experimental efforts to you
know improve our Quantum chipset is
getting improved
um certainly I'm shocked at how good the
quantum device is at the same time it
seems like this new observation of
noise-induced free transition is very
interesting but at the same time as we
will discuss further I have a few kind
of unresolved questions that I would
like to discuss further especially
regarding the notion of facial lesion
and the notion of what it means it
cannot be spooked so maybe we will delay
you know like talking about discussions
at a later stage yeah
okay maybe I'll go next if you don't
mind a soon one
um uh so yeah so thanks for the very
nice talk I really enjoyed it I really
like seeing these sort of larger and
sort of more sophisticated uh less noisy
random Quantum circuit experiment I
think it's really important if only uh
sort of as a means of benchmarking right
to try to uh you know compare and sort
of an Apples to Apples manner sort of
successive generations of uh you know
um of quantum experiments that the
Google team is doing and I think from
that perspective you know these results
about sort of when you know when in
terms of the you know noise rates uh
we're seeing correspondence between xcb
and Fidelity you know is is is really
important right because Fidelity is a
very important Quantum Benchmark
um you know and uh but it's not sample
efficient and xcb you can you can
estimate with for you know far fewer
samples and so I think there's every
indication that xcb is going to be a
really important measure for us as we
sort of go forward
um you know in fact it's so important
one thing I want to say from the get-go
is that we have you know together with a
uh you know really smart group of
researchers at
UMD we've actually been able to see
similar things um and I think we'll have
a paper uh forthcoming uh we're really
studying um you know exactly what xcb
has to do with Fidelity and in what
situations we we hope to see it but I
think we're mostly in agreement the one
thing I want to say though in terms of
complexity is I think the situation is a
little bit more nuanced I mean from my
perspective uh you know maybe the the
main message I'm getting from many of
these talks on noisy random circuit
sampling is just that you know when I
think about the power of noisy random
circuits it's really a multi-parameter
problem you know there's not a single
answer the the the the answer really
depends on what do we mean by noise
right I mean in our first um in our
first paper you know on this on this
subject with umash and Adam and and so
on you know we weren't really thinking
about noise at all we were asking this
much simpler question if you you know
Implement to send actually a perfect
noiseless system you know is there is
there a signal or not uh you know and
that was not obvious at all and now
we're asking this question you know can
we model the noise realistically and is
there you know a complexity theoretic
sense in which it's hard and I think
that really depends on what you mean you
know I think what what noise are you
talking about are you talking about
depolarizing noise in particular are you
talking about other noise correlated
noise unital noise or non-unitable noise
I think we're discovering that all of
these things are important what is the
noise strength right so I think that's
one of the main differences that we were
talking here are we talking about
constant noise strength that doesn't
change as the system size grows or does
the noise get sort of um in some sense
better as a system size grows does it
scale like some constant over the system
size which means as the system size is
getting larger the noise in some senses
getting is getting less
um you know um are we talking about
finite size systems or are we talking
about scaling all right and I think what
we're learning is that all of these
things matter and they matter a lot that
really depends on if we get easiness and
classical easiness like we saw you know
a few months back I think there was a
really great colloquium here at Simon's
Institute where we were looking at
um where you know yunchao and dorit
taharanov and Umesh and others were
thinking about constant noise rate
depolarizing uh noise
um in the asymptotic setting right and
there they had a very nice algorithm
that got easiness a classical easiness
but of course here we're we're talking
about something completely different and
the answer might be different so to me I
think it just matters how are we
modeling
um you know this sort of very
complicated uh you know phenomenon of
quantum noise that complexity theoretic
setting and I think what we're learning
more and more every day is it just
really depends on uh what we're modeling
so that's sort of my takeaway in the
complexity Department
yeah cool um maybe I'll just make one uh
additional comment following up on that
um yeah I guess like it's nice that they
rather than just kind of repeating the
old experiment with a bigger system and
like uh you know better Gates they've
actually kind of been gone further and
analyzed this whole phase transition
stuff and I think it really highlights
how random circuit sampling is you know
while it may not have a direct practical
application that's obvious it's really
kind of a test bed or like all of these
very fundamental questions of like
hardness and like what's going on with
this noise and so I think like I really
appreciate that they've kind of tried to
focus on this in the in this iteration
of of things and uh while I think what
Bill said is definitely right that like
there's all these dimensions and we
still have so much to understand I think
it's nice to see like a building
consensus maybe
um
between like this paper he mentioned
earlier where we know now
that at constant uh error rate per you
know per gate so this would be an
extensive number of Errors per cycle uh
there is a you know polynomial time
algorithm that that works and here kind
of now there's a consensus that if the
noise is is weak enough in this kind of
simplified model where we're only having
a small constant number of Errors per
cycle then uh there's kind of a more
robust argument for uh hardness
um and or there's this whole space in
between and there's all these different
kinds of noise like Bill was saying but
um you know I think we're kind of as a
community maybe understanding it better
which is encouraging
yeah I would also like to definitely
talk about the spoofing stuff that um
soon was alluding to because I was also
curious to hear that especially soon
wants to take on on this um I guess yeah
I guess the the question for me was like
uh yeah it seems clear that there's some
some sort of transition of some kind you
know uh uh going on between a very weak
noise regime and like a stronger noise
regime that's still a constant Over N uh
uh uh error rate per gate
um but I guess yeah once you cross over
into the into the strong noise regime I
guess it's very unclear to me uh what's
going on like it it seems like the
Fidelity is no longer the or the the FCB
is no longer going to match up with the
um
uh right the the probability of having
no errors over the whole algorithm this
like f to the D quantity but uh do we
know that suddenly it becomes easy in
some sense or like there is a way to
spoof and I guess conversely in this
very weak noise regime do we know that
you can't spoof um
neither of these seem obvious to me
um but yeah I think the other panelists
could maybe say better
yeah
go ahead someone and Bill
yeah so
um so let's let's try to open up like
one one discussion Point each regarding
the benchmarking we we use the same word
benchmarking but I recently learned
actually that reason like uh we learned
one year ago that actually means two
different things depending on the
different community
one is benchmarking the capab you know
Hardware you know correctness how good
this Quantum device is you know compared
to say Fidelity is one or not
um the other one is benchmarking
computation power you know how does it
compare against
your computer doing similar tasks where
the task needs to be well defined
these are a little subtle but this is
sharply different it's a conceptually
different notion because one is
computational aspect the other one is
more Hardware aspect so like I mean both
very interesting but somehow like I
think we should not kind of mix up those
two concepts let's focus on the first
one first like uh you know checking the
hardware is behaving in a way that we
expect it to behave so I do have a
question for Sergio so okay like if we
talk to an experimentalist one of the
obvious things that we should try is
either of the two either before evolve
in unitary and then apply inverse unit
row and come back to the initial State
and see how well it comes back to the
original state second task is is why you
guys are already simulated the Clipper
circuit and the clipboard circuit forms
redesign for the pivot therefore we can
efficiently do the xcb even for the all
connected it connectivity like in
regardless of the geometry so I was
wondering whether we have considered
actually using either clipboard or the
kind versus you know unitary is to check
the the expected behavior from the
quantum chipset and if it's not then I
would like to learn about what the
difficulty is doing so
yeah so the first one doing a loss with
Echo
um that one
um
actually acoustic and told you about
that because that hasn't been we have
done that
um but you have to change the gates a
little bit so in the case that we used
to sort of get the maximum computational
power
you know because we're indeed doing both
the benchmarks as you say right here we
care about both of them we care about
Fidelity system errors but we also care
about the computational cause Benchmark
so to maximize the computational cons
Benchmark we use these eye swap ligates
so they have this extra control C phase
and
that makes them harder to Embark because
you have you have this extra phase
uh this is a lot easier to invert if you
just declare that to be an eye swap
because you know it kind of inverts with
single qubit Gates so that's what was
done on the what we call the information
scrambling experiment
and experiments like that I mean
internally and you know it matches what
you expect with this caveat right uh so
the reason why we don't you know do it
here
is uh this extra phase that we keep
um
sorry does this extra phase is something
you cannot eliminate in the in your
circuit for the new chipset well you can
eliminate it but at the cost of
um lower Fidelity it's just the physical
way that the gate is implemented to kind
of eliminate it turns out you have to
make the gate longer so there is kind of
a compromise you know to get the higher
possible fidelity
right those are just experimental
control details of how the gate is
physically implemented
um so you don't make it absolutely
thorough but you can make it smaller but
make it longer Gates but longer Gates
they are longer so you know T1 is still
around so they just have a slightly
lower Fidelity
um which so that's why we don't do it in
this experiment but
um you know we have done it internally
it's probably reported an information
scrubbing paper for instance right
because yeah
yeah another question about Cliffords
um you can do xcp with Cliffords but
there are you know larger fluctuations
so the average would be the same but you
know not like Circuit by Circuit so then
you have to do like a lot of circuits
um we actually didn't do that
it's the same in other words right
but you know Clippers fluctuate by an
order one
um you know kind of constant
um so you have to just average many
circuits between the end yeah but sorry
I'm confused
isn't the amount of fluctuations if
we're only by factor of maybe three or
four like order one factor because it's
just redesign
um
I don't know to be honest and also do
you need to use eye swaps which is what
we're not using we still have this
control c space right
that's right but but the one comment
that I wanted to make is as a theorist
you know instead of I mean at some
region we need to go to the region we
cannot simulate I totally say that but
here it's done by having two different
patching like half one third one third
one third but maybe what makes like the
theorists happier will be exactly the
same geometry but one is an ensemble
Clifford and the other one is just in
print some phases in a controlled
fashion just change the content of the
circuit without changing the geometry or
the any architecture of the circuit
um but otherwise it remains exactly the
same and they maintain the same Fidelity
that would be amazing
we actually did that in back in 2021 the
science that I was citing on one of the
slides we did exactly that for we were
not measuring xzb we were measuring a
very closely related quantity which is
out of time order correlator for local
uh operators
and you can think of linear exhibit as
just some over all possible out of time
or the correlators
so we we actually did exactly that we
out of time order correlator is actually
plus or minus one for Clifford circuit
so it's very convenient very easy to
measure and then as we and we could
control the content of The Circuit by
adding uh t-gates
and controlling the number of cigarettes
I don't see the convergence and we could
see the change in the behavior a
particularly the average as we expect
from uh out of time order correlator and
linear exhibit were the same so the
average to the same value but the
fluctuations were different and we could
see that in experiment how fluctuations
depend
on the uh so this is fourth moment right
that is different in the in the
Cliffords and in the universal circuit
right we could see how they depend on
the content of the circuit so yeah
please uh if you are interested have a
look and I'm happy to discuss more
details about about that experiment
we also need but you know back in 2019
allied with circuitry which is almost
the same but just removing a few Gates
and that's when we could simulate not as
easily as clay for circuits but
we did that the first time which I think
in retrospect it was a good idea because
now we're realizing that you know you
have to be very careful
um there's a big difference between
patches and the full circle because
there are per layer is very different
and you know we could have been on the
brown side of the face transition in
2019 but because we did this highlighted
circuits we know that we were in the
right phase
right I'm wondering if I can maybe uh go
back to some pesky questions about
complexity Theory
um so uh so first of all can I um just
confirm when you're talking about
complexity in this sort of you know in
this particular regime in which the you
know the noise is uh you know uh
something like some constant over n and
you think that xcb corresponds to
Fidelity and so on I assume what you
what you mean is that for the sort of
fixed system size and that fixed noise
rate that the sort of current state of
the art you know tensor Network methods
um you know do not work well to simulate
the system in a small amount of human
time as as compared with running time
um is that is that how you're thinking
about it I just wanted to confirm well
there is a relation that you know I
think will be a good idea to discuss
which we didn't quite explain in the
talk because it's kind of a technical to
explain between sure like we do that you
know we compare with tensor networks to
compare with tensor Networks is more you
know to just kind of get the best
um yeah what what all of that is known
and you put it in some optimization
formula and you run you know large
optimizations to basically find the best
contraction orderings and
um vertex projections and reorderings
and things like that so there are just a
lot of tricks an easiest numerics at
that point now for the
um for this poof in there is a sort of a
stronger relation with with I think what
you know Sumo was saying before
or or even like that algorithm from you
know
um Ole Miss and read and others um and
that's just saying well you know
um I mean of course those
spoofing attacks interview
asymptotically and we agree you know
that's why we're saying like the other
parameter is
error per layer you could you know you
cannot agree you don't scale right many
things break down give you a scale and
the number of qubits with constant
errors that doesn't work but if you have
a low enough error per layer then I
think the Fidelity that you get with the
spoofing methods and and that's
something we still talk about is lower
than the Fidelity that we're reporting
experimentally and it's not quite the
same transition but it's a you know is
is around
the same point
of in the transitions I think that that
may be something interesting to discuss
yeah I I I'm actually I have a question
along that line too so the way I
understood the talk is a phase edition
of other entire layer
um the you know depending on the amount
of matter you have a two different
regimes where xcb closely follows the
Fidelity or xcb and then Fidelity
diverges you know as the death increases
right so okay so that's that's very
natural in fact I think it has been
pointed out in several other papers I I
don't remember all of them but one of
them is my own paper we shown now we we
studied that so I'm not kind of in such
a very consistent and I think that's a
good understanding but I'm confused
about how to build
proofing
because when it comes to spoofing
while it's spoofing like what is the
object being exposed or always spoofing
to achieve better exhibit because like
you know the here so okay
when you say spoofing like what is the
things that's being scooped
foreign
a little bit at the beginning you can
simplify to say you're something for a
mixture of the ideal probabilities with
you know identity that turns out not to
be good enough for the experiment so
then it's a mixture of something which
looks like the
a mixture of the ideal probabilities
with the maximum State or the uniform
distribution but not quite you have to
allow for some tolerance there and and
then the goal is to sample from that
distribution
with you know some Fidelity which is
like the mixture parameter in this
picture F uh but that's you know sort of
a mouthful so then I think it makes you
know and it's instructed to just you
know for all that let's let's you know
at least in this case where like we're
saying like we're in the weak there's a
gym we can Define the Fidelity and in
most of the spoofing I think you end up
it still makes sense to just use cross
entropy as an estimator of difficulty
which is the parameter I can look around
so I think that's an interesting thing
to study you know spoofy means well as
long as you know you're sampling I mean
because there are many things you can do
to increment cross entropy which is not
sampling yes calculate 100 probabilities
choose the large one and just keep
outputting that beta stream that's
really not sampling and that you know
it's a way to maximize your centerpieces
there are some details that anyway this
is the reason why I prefer to talk about
the sample in person but anyway
um it's still instead of to just keep
going back to the Cross entropy and then
I guess what we're trying to say is that
um the spoofy methods that we know about
um you know once you're in the work
University I'm not exactly the
transition that we're talking about a
bit lower the spoofing methods will not
achieve the same
um meaning polynomial classical
algorithms right
uh will not achieve the same cross
entropy or Fidelity that what we report
in the experiment
and I think what difference free paper
for instance is
um we're taking the limit of D to
Infinity right we just need to keep the
error per layer constant
but in principle you can go to very
large steps and you know everything
still works as long as they're probably
is constant even not very large depth of
course there are reasons why you cannot
go to very large that experimental is
because the you know Fidelity is
decreasing so the number of samples that
you will need to take would increases
financially with depths anyway but it's
not a question about the spoofing
anymore it's a question about the
experiment just require into many
samples
so wait does um does this algorithm that
uh that student one worked on
um a few years ago where you kind of
just like you delete a few of the gates
and you simulate each half and then you
you know produce an output and then it
doesn't do anything close to simulating
the actual circuit but it turns out to
have
um you know a decent score on the
cross-entry bench ranking so you're
saying that this algorithm would not be
competitive
with uh the quantum output when the
noise is so low
we can actually make a precise statement
yes for it there is a there is an
analogous phase transition this is
slightly different it's only a different
way factor from the noise induced phase
transition after which
the the spoofing exhib linear exhibit
that you can achieve is exponentially
smaller than the one you're measuring in
the okay and this is related to this the
statmic stuff that you were saying at
the end or
um yes I actually I have a slide that I
can to make it even more provocative I
can show it if we if that's okay
uh on this yeah so but but just to make
sure I'm I'm on the same page so on the
leading order what you mean by spoofing
is a specific class of task where you
first represent a wave function that has
a high note Fidelity using tensor
networks and then doing the task of
sampling by Contracting them
is maybe not possible in the regime when
you know elevator error per layer is
small but it's not about spoofing open
to entire set of algorithms like not
even our owns but it's like a spoofing
is not possible for a certain specific
set about tax is that it's a good
understanding and then constia is going
to talk about as a separate slide about
like something relevant to our previous
work is it is that is that good
understanding so far
no sorry so in the talk we are very
careful to compare against sensor and it
works because those are the algorithms
that are you know actually competitive
meaning like they actually reproduce you
know the sampling from 2019 so they're
the ones that are actually ahead right
and also
um I think that MPS algorithms kind of
covers in a way like uh maybe algorithms
that you can work on right because you
work on like you know what happens if
they just have two halves these
algorithms say like I'll simulate two
house but actually you know it's half of
one dimension in the middle and and
anyway and then we care about you know
bonding how much memory you need even
without carrying over the computational
costs so we do that but when we're
talking about the spoofing now we talk
about those are you know still all those
potential algorithms and it's a question
of there is potential you know but but
um but if you work on them even if the
cost is financial you can reduce the
cost by non-trivial you know you do it
on the spot end until you actually beat
this payment right but what we mean by
spoofing is polynomial algorithms right
like the one for a woman but you know
any any polynomial algorithm though not
just specific ones that we've seen or
maybe that's the point I think I guess
not any we cannot say generally like any
algorithm but algorithms maybe because
they will explain on the slide that look
like you know you have like some
representation of your function and then
you kind of you know you apply your gate
and then you do something to simplify
your referencing that looks like noise
sure and that's kind of you get the
relation which doesn't cover necessarily
all polynomial experiences you know but
but I think it covers you know at least
the ones from Zoom one and they might
cover more you know like you can model
them you know by maybe you know it's
just I mean someone you said that this
place in the new paper the noisiest
kills completely like these links you
concentrate on the noise somewhere so it
covers like algorithms in that family
right well I'm not I'm not 100 convinced
yet about that yeah that's that's why it
will be good to discuss it yes
okay
so if I do that uh sure if you is is
that uh in a few minutes
yeah
let me go here
yeah so uh again do you see my slides
yes yes so so this is uh spoofing assert
yourself we think of it as a polynomial
as an algorithm that doesn't try to
solve the actual computational task
instead it tries to produce and output
that in by some measure is as good as
the output of the noisy hardware and in
this case we will talk about linear xzb
because that's what we're talking about
I mean
yep
that will be the criteria for this case
and the simplest example was in the in
the paper by someone and others
where you can just split
the circuit delete the gates from the
circuit in such a way that you simulate
two half of the system
and the remarkable observation is that
this in this case if you calculate xzb
between this
wave function and the ideal wave
function is actually Larson zero at
least up to some
oops
um
but uh kind of what we learned from
studying noise and use phase transition
is the spoofing there is a boundary
between where uh this exhibit from this
type of spoofing where we slice the
circuit
uh or in other ways we add errors but in
a controlled way
uh in this case we expect that there is
a transition as well in the spoofing at
some point which differs by a factor a
from the noise and use phase transition
and the way kind of to get intuition why
this happens is we can go back to this
weakling model which is the kind of the
that allows analytical solution a linear
exhibit for it was consisting of this
contribution of actual Fidelity right of
the whole system and then the
contribution that was proportional to
Fidelity of the half the system right
either A or B
you know both actually and and this
factor that determines the rate of
convergence to
Quantum colors in some sense to an
organic state
and the idea what you what you can do in
spoofing is uh you can place this you
use the simulation which is not noisy
writers but you don't want to simulate
the whole system right so the only
assumption we need to make here is that
you cannot simulate the actual portal
Thomas distribution right just because
you're spoofing right that will take
exponential time you're doing a smaller
simulation in that sense you're
exploiting exploiting the terms that are
actually Vanishing at the equals to
Infinity so these are these terms
exactly and we can put an upper bound on
the storms
by just putting Fidelity to one here so
just take this
and the spoofing is successful is what
when we obtain this in this without a
full simulation we obtain an exhibit
that is larger than the Fidelity
of the actual experiment
right and we can again upper bound this
exhibit and and this condition that
Fidelity is uh smaller than this
this actually means that a equals to one
half
so for this model we see that there is a
boundary actually uh so I am confused in
this formula if I just read it as it is
we have xcb similar one plus two Lambda
so do you obtain the xcp that's larger
than one and redone already like I'm a
little bit confused
FD FD plus two Lambda DRT right
uh which one are you talking about
uh the one plus two Lambda D to the
previous line
a little bit further
this one
well it actually initially you write
FD plus to Lambda FD score to 50 but
then you just you know
right you just keep the one there that's
this oh yeah so this is a kind of a this
is Noise free exhibit this is kind of in
principle what we do you would kind of
Maximum exhibit you can have right but
what's important is in the spoofing
because you are not simulating uh you
are not using exponential exponential
algorithm
you are can only take advantage of the
terms that are transient that is not a
steady state of the random circuit
you're right but let me argue okay so I
think we move the one there or you're
looking at XUV plus one when you write
out the question yeah this the extra one
is the thing that is confusing
time converges to one right well not if
you're a spoofing right
yeah yeah yeah so this this like Wiggly
uh bracket means that spoofing can only
reproduce this part cannot reproduce the
one yeah I agree but I have a comment so
here you assume that you are right we
are exploiting the components coming
from F to the power D over 2 and
therefore you're replacing with the
maximum value one but actually the
maximum value is not one it's actually
exponentially large the reason it could
be exponentially right but usually it
doesn't have to be the reason being we
have an exact description of the wave
function of the halfway system
therefore you can do the anniversarial
sampling to just sample the same B
strings that has a probability that's
larger than the you know the inverse
dimension of the subsystem therefore by
replacing it to one you are assuming
that we just do the kind of perfect
sampling but in fact we can do Amplified
adversarial sampling to make this
contribution even larger than one
that that's I think what's missing in
this analysis
um honestly yeah what building is that
our algorithm we we did our best using
one GPU
um desktop computer and then computation
didn't actually outperform you know this
circuit uh for the same Fidelity table
larger system we did outperform the the
70 Cubit actually system if you had not
included fidelity but now that this
chipset has improved Fidelity we are not
100 sure we can outperform you know
these chipsets but this argument in my
view does not actually you know like uh
proves that our user would not
work well so there is there is an
additional Factor you can win by
resampling indeed but that also you need
to resemble for a very long time right
there is an additional cost yeah also I
need to remind you that there's a
question on the chat so maybe
yeah yeah we should we should get there
but so before we get there Bill were you
trying to did you have some comment
about complexity or should we move on no
I have plenty of comments about complex
yeah go ahead I wanted to maybe change
the topic just a little bit um I was
very interested in what you were talking
about when you were saying talking about
the white noise regime
um and I'm actually interested in that
because
um you know someone else on this panel
Alex in particular you know has papers
where he he sort of looks at somewhat
related scenarios where he says you know
if the noise is sufficiently small if
it's like one over n or some one over n
log n or something like this you know
you you have white noise regime which
means that the noise again is sort of
uncorrelated with the uh the signal in a
certain sense and then you know we can
actually sometimes get complexity
theoretic arguments that are really
formal back
um but then you know so
let's just assume that that's what we're
trying to to reach this sort of white
noise regime I think a lot of the uh xcb
Theory we're talking about sort of
assumes that in some sense but I wanted
to ask you you sort of had this comment
where you said that's not actually what
you see in the experiment right
um and and I sort of assume it's because
there are some there's some biased noise
maybe certainly a readout and things
like that but I sort of want to just
just see how close are we do you think
to to seeing something that would be
like uh like white noise and and is that
just a bad model or is it that it's sort
of a good model but it doesn't
characterize all of the um the noise and
then what you know how what what exactly
is going on with this this white noise
or This Global you know depolarizing in
your opinion
well I mean um
um I guess the
uh well first of course we have readout
bias so that's that's for sure you can
see that yeah very easily um yeah yeah
that's fine order by I mean distance and
that's probably non-unitor right
um no that's not unitalia right right
not the case the state one yeah exactly
yeah but there's probably something in
between the the gates too right it's not
just about the readout or or no
um
I mean it's very hard to characterize I
mean we have like you know multiple
models of what noise we have yeah for it
for instance we have some liquids right
at some point and you know leakage um is
not markovia right like we I mean is is
kind of a smaller than another source of
noise in the case of
on the Miracle correction we care a lot
about likas because it's a very uh
dangerous type of noise so we actually
measure it Unbound it and things like
that but look at is once you populate
you know a higher state which is not a
cubit it just takes a bit to relax you
have to do several tricks to you know to
actually relax it right things like that
some there are all these kinds of things
they're also high energy events like
cosmic rays things like that so no no
yeah that I I understand no but I guess
I'm asking like is there is there a sort
of you know how much are we simplifying
in some non-quantitative sense when we
thought when we talk about this um White
Noise picture is it something that you
think is essentially right but there's a
little bit of sort of Epsilon other
stuff going on or is it maybe there's a
really quantitative difference between
the heart the the hardness that we see
for the noise and the white noise model
I guess it depends what you're looking
at you know if you sort of one group
data streams like if you do histograms
and things like that then you kind of
whiten it a little you know and we often
do histograms like when we do the
comparison with a common office middle
model things like that then you whiten
it a little bit because you're just
doing some groupings of probabilities
then it works really well if you don't
group probabilities at all then
you know you can see a difference and
actually
um we also did some particular
experiment when you when we inject like
a particular
um
discrete error somewhere and then you
know you really have to take into
account that it's really not fully
depolarized at all because I mean it
depends with how much Precision you look
at the noise I guess
Sergio so is you the reason you think
that it's not the White Noise models is
just because you're seeing non-uniform
outputs like biased towards zero or one
or can you say again maybe I missed
um
um we see non-uniform outputs by S40 or
one for sure
and back in 2019
um you know we were studying
if when we introduce like one exactly
one error like by some coherent angle
you know would like one error sort of
gives you the Fidelity that we expect
which is a very specific kind of noise
just like one computer in the middle of
the circuit and it we couldn't interpret
the data for a while and it was because
you know we had to remember that we
really had to to think of the model as
you know like errors Brigade and not not
really like a globally depolarizing
model so that was one particular
experiment right which you know we did
the experiment and we couldn't
understand the data until we realized we
were using the global LED policy model
and it just didn't see them work
I I see because it's like you you could
be close
like it would be hard to verify that
you're far from this white noise
distribution like you'd have to
you know repeat the experiment an
exponential number of times to like see
that it's not exactly the number it
should be like I mean it's easy to see
when there's some bias at the end that
gives you more zeros and ones but if
there's some
something wrong in the middle or it's
just not you know we in our paper we
only analyzed unitol heart random noise
uh which is very narrow so you know if
there's some deviation from that that's
causing something I don't know how one
would experimentally
detect it
well not with many keywords I guess
um yeah but you know yeah with you know
with a smaller number of cubits you can
right
I guess I guess one uh one effect maybe
that that could uh build and maybe that
could like lead to a deviation from the
White Noise assumption
um at like
shallower depths even so even if you're
beneath this threshold where you can
like uh you know this Epsilon so you
know some constant Over N threshold
where you're kind of expecting it to all
work out
um there's still this yeah this
competition between you know kind of
like what someone was saying like
there's this uh this Benchmark xcp
quantity that starts at like two to the
end and actually it like goes all the
way down to constant in like log time
um and then it starts decaying and then
while the Fidelity starts at one and it
decays and the idea is like if the
Fidelity is decaying slower then
eventually this thing that started to
the end will become smaller than the
thing that started at one
um but actually like
I think if if you're kind of just below
the transition but you're not that far
below the transition the point where
these cross might be like actually very
far and and some of the numerics we did
in this paper that you mentioned like
suggested that actually you need a lot
more gates than what they can do
um like then the what are being done in
the in the experiments now to kind of
have this crossover actually have
happened although we can't really
simulate the exact experiment because
it's like how did the number of gates
scale is it like n log n or something or
something else it would still be uh it
would still be like uh yeah and well the
number of layers would be login so
there'd be like n log n Gates but the
constant in front of the N log n would
get bigger as you get closer to the
transition point I think I see I got it
and as you go all the way to the
transition point it would become like
infinite uh this transition they would
never cross right
um yeah so
but I don't know how you would detect
that in the experiment so uh not sure I
guess you could do it at a small system
size where you can calculate well even
then you have to
yeah you have to repeat a lot of times
to characterize your whole distribution
that's a very interesting um
discussion yeah so um
so I I guess Sergio can you can you see
in a in a simple way what
you know what you actually see
experimentally or do you do you have a
you have a notion of what these
that that the noise maybe gives you
you think it's it's not right noise but
it's independent or some some other some
other way of thinking about
um
yeah I guess the best
um model I have is what I try to put in
the
on the third slide which is you know as
long as the noise is independent of the
real probabilities
and does not concentrate that property
too much then cross entropy works yeah
and then you know because he's still not
um concentrating you anywhere and you
can just group probabilities and things
like that you're gonna get
and things like that are going to work
just fine other tests like um because
look at tests like Collision
probabilities
will work is fine so that's sort of the
the best model I have we
um
you know the two instances we personally
look at were they read that bias and
also this other case in the paper where
we purposely introduced like some extra
phase and and try to see that it was
decreasing the Fidelity uh as expected
and we just couldn't get it to work out
until we remember
you know that the totally deployers in
China was just uh
a model right we have to actually take
into account that this you know sequence
of gates and how that knows what's
spreading and things like that right
but maybe that's a special case because
we were introducing Noise by hand
[Music]
maybe should we uh should we see from
Manuel
um you had a question do you want to go
ahead and ask
okay
I think it's in the it's in the chat but
uh Manila do you want to go ahead and
ask that uh by unmuting
maybe
um
since it has to do with your papers and
one do you want to yeah
they were asking uh what happens with a
quantities such as FC introduced in you
know manual and my you know
collaborations uh the idea is you know
it's a very short time depth when the
activity is very large where Fidelity is
of course upper bounded by one in fact
you can use empirical formula by just
dividing FX EB by the you know the ideal
value of xav and turns out in
particularly we see that you know this
already captures the reality very well
in the same regime error rate per layer
is not so good so in some sense that
also brings connection to the you know
questionable facial distance like in
what sense interface condition it could
be that you just modified of you know
formula for the xcb by proper
normalization then we can now construct
the object that seems to follow the
Fidelity so it's just that the estimator
is not good in this region because of
non-linear Behavior so do you have any
comments about that
question you wanna
answer that
I don't quite understand how you
construct the procedures divide by the
ideal yeah yeah so the XC is basically
correlating probability from the
experiment and probably of the ideal
case
well you could consider say F ideal
where this is just both perfect
probabilities
and because at store time it's not yet
anti-concentrated this value will be
very large at a short time what we do is
we divide this xcb by this new
quantitative Fido and this turns out
this quantity has an interpretation as a
you know in terms of spin language it's
related to the average expectation value
of the magnetization the the small
perturbation of the noise therefore it
still estimate the amount of the
Fidelity reduction very well
in practice would there be large
fluctuations uh in your estimate because
so you need to sample a lot but turns
out this decays pretty rapidly so in the
region we're during Regional is so at T
for one after one layer maybe it's not
reasonable to do this but layer two or
three it already converges very quickly
and manual is now like on his computer
so maybe
sorry I was on the wrong computer
already because we had a group meeting
now yeah I agree with someone I think it
also relates to the question of global
White Noise because this new estimator
you can basically show it works also if
you don't have Global white noise so
um in particular you just need an error
that's spread locally
so I wonder like why not use that one
it's clearly the better estimate and
basically Fidelity converges to fxcp for
deep circuits and works for shallower
circuits so it should be the preferred
quantity generally for random circuits
in our opinion why not use them for this
one do you still have to face transition
these are the two questions
it seems like the useful regime for this
quantity is before what we call
anti-concentration right foreign
by definition therefore it works for all
regimes like automatically takes care of
the short time at the daytime together
so it works equally at the meantime yeah
yeah but the phase transition the way is
this fine try to exhibition conversion
to Fidelity only happens Beyond
anti-consideration we need to take
sufficient depth
so it's in this sense I say yes it will
show the same the same behavior
so we read the paper and the dynamic of
featuring Edition is another facing
machine to talk about yeah and we are
talking about that face Edition
happens earlier
yes
what is the question then because here
there's no you know no Crossing because
this modified formula is always Upper
Valley from one and he seems to agree
with the Fidelity in all regimes as long
as error per layer is sufficiently small
so do we clear
I mean you're not talking about a
different phase transition not the one
we cover in the talk but in the paper we
talk in a different transition which is
related to anti-concentration what
you're saying if you normalize you know
the cross entropy as as you explain by
just dividing by the corresps then you
wouldn't see
the phase transition system which is
related to the concentration because
you're normalizing it away
would you will still see the face
transition that we talk about today
um you know we didn't want to cover the
other one because it's just more stuff
and I think that's the answer like yeah
I think I agree we'll smooth out you
know the first transition
and but it will still the transition
that we were talking about today within
the wing and Astronaut regime because
the fast transition is about
anti-concentration that the one will be
smooth out
the second transition which is about
weak to a strong noise at the interval
is still be there even with that
estimator and the question why we don't
use that I mean I think if you are
working at low depth that's a great you
know thing to do and we don't always use
cross entropy as presented here um for
like two qubits we don't use that
equation we use cross entropy but we do
something else
um but the reason why we use these
equations as well is because well first
we we want to be begin at the
concentration point because we also care
about the computational Benchmark part
and and then you know we want to have
large enough depth so that we have some
confidence that things are you know
quite entangled and using these other
formulas allow us to compare linear to
logarithmic or entropy for instance and
make sure that they give the same
estimate
so and you know that's one way to sort
of check that that we have enough depth
and things are working properly like but
yeah I mean and also for to use that
equation I guess you have to calculate
you know what happens with the ideal
probabilities and I'll have to think
about that if you can use the same ones
that you're sampling in the experiment
but you probably have to use another one
so at least sample uniformly beta
streams right to estimate the quantity
in the denominator
and that is more computational cost I
guess
um
but I mean for load apps I mean there's
I'm sure there are circumstances you
know with these other estimator is
pretty useful
I'm nothing against it I I have to I
really have to switch to another meeting
yeah actually I was gonna say um
yeah we're probably out of time now but
uh thank you again uh uh question uh
stay here for
that was a really nice nice uh talk
really nice work that you spoke about
and uh thanks Alex and Bill and so on
for a library panel
uh so and with that this is um this is
the last Collective of the of the series
so
um
thanks everyone for joining and um look
forward to seeing you in the poll
thanks
and